[موسيقى]
مرحبا اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه جميعا
يعطيكم العافيه يا دكتوره ريما ودكتور نور
الدين رخصت عليه كتير
الموضوع اللي انا جاي احكي فيه قبل ما
ابلش
بدي اسالكم سؤال هل التطور او التكنولوجيا
خلقت ناس اعتماديه ولا هي سهلت حياتنا هذا
السؤال كثير مخترع على بال اغلب الناس
ولكن من وجهه نظري فالذكاء الاصطناعي فتح
مجالات كتير للاشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه انهم
يقدروا يشاركوا بالمجتمع
انا شخصيا واحد من الناس اللي بعتمد كثير
على الذكاء الاصطناعي لما اطلع بالسياره
بنادي على جوجل
عشان تاخذني على اللوكيشن المعين بنادي
على جوجل
من غير ما انا عطله يعني انا اعمل ولا اي
حركه غير اني انا اركز
حتى بالبيت انا واحد من الناس اللي كنت
كتير اتعب واتغلب واغلب الناس معاي عشان
اطفي قبل ما انام
ولكن برضه بفضل الذكاء الاصطناعي عم بقدر
اني انا اعمل كل هذا الحكي من غير ما
اتحرك من مكاني
كتير بالذات الناس اللي مو من عمرنا او
خلينا نحكي الكبار عم بشوفه ان الزكاه
الاصطناعي خلق اشخاص اعتماديين انه هاي
الاعتماديه لشوف هم مو عارفين انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي عم بسهل حياه الاشخاص من ذوي
الاعاقه بشكل اكبر مما انتم تتخيلوا حتى
انا سعيد قصاص وانا اكثر من مجرد مسمى
اغلبكم يمكن يكون سمع هذه الجمله قبل هيك
ولكن بحالي انتم ما سمعتوها انا سعيد قصاص
انا مهندس برمجيات متحدث تحفيزي وزاره في
حقوق الاشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه كوني اوفيس
لي واحمل الاشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه
[تصفيق]
الذين نقدر نحكي اكثر عن المستقبل لازم
نحكي عن الماضي
لو المحاضره هذه كانت ببدايه التسعينات
كان اغلبكم انصدم انه في بني ادم من ذوي
الاعاقه واقف على مسرح ولكن بفضل
التكنولوجيا والتطور
انه احنا نوصل المعلومه بشكل اكبر بفضل
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وحتى استخدامنا كاشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه
لمواقع لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اول
السوشيال ميديا عم بيكون اسهل هل تعلم ان
الشخص الكفيف بقدر يفتح موقع زي فيسبوك
وانستجرام بفضل الاو سي ار او اللي هو
وحتى بفضل الابل
طبعا مستخدمين زيكم ليش لانه انت لما ترفع
صوره على الانستقرام انت ما بتقطعها فقط
على الانستجرام انت بترفعها على كلاود
ضخمه بتحلل هاي الصوره وبتقول
بتجمع الداتا عن هاي الصوره انه هذا شجره
فيها بيت فيها سياره نوع السياره واحد
اثنين ثلاثه نسوان
بعدين بيجي شخص كيف بفتح الانستقرام بلاقي
صوره لشجره
ببلش الاو سي ار
نقلوه ايش موجود بهذه الصوره
اكبر من هيك اللي هو عنا اللي هو جوجل
جوجل
شخصيا
تفاجات انه قدر يوصف لي تقريبا كل اشي
موجود حوالي بالغرفه اني في باب في ابسط
قدامك لما عرفت على الباب بلش الموبايل
يهز بصوره كتير قويه انه انتبه في باب
قدامك
وصلت ابعد من هيك بفضل عدسه اللايكا
الكاميرات المتطوره انه بيقدر يحكي لك
الباب هذا كيف بفتح هل هو
بني ادم كفيف يكون معتمد على التكنولوجيا
عشان يقدر يكمل بحياته قد ايه عم بتكون
حياته اسهل وهذا كمان زي ما حكينا لموضوع
داتا فانت كل ما تستعملوا السوشيال ميديا
اكثر كل ما عملته انا لموضوع البرايف اكثر
انه خلي الابلكيشن هذا يتبع انت شو بتعمل
انت شو حركتك يعني هاي الداتا كلياتها لما
تتجمع عم بتساعد اشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه
انهم يوصلوا
انا واحد من الناس واضحه قدامكم انه انا
منطق عندي شويه صعب
اليكسا او جوجل
عنا حاليا
انا جلست اني انا ادرب جوجل اسيستنت انها
تفهم علي بالرغم من صعوبه نطق بعض الكلمات
جوجل اسيستنت وقالت له هلا بتقدر تدربها
اذا انت بتعاني من التاتاه
انك تاخذ اخر كلمه انت حكيتها فقط
طبعا هذا الاشي كمان على موضوع
اللي هو قد ايه الموبايل اللي قدامك اقصص
انك انت تبرمجه على حسب حالتك انت في ناس
عندها رشفه بايدها فانت بتقدر تمنع
الاكسجين اللي هي اللمسات الغير مرغوب
فيها نهايه تاخذ اخر امر انت اعطيتها اياه
وبالنهايه
اول نقطه
كلياتنا
من مر بصعوبات
ومرات الصعوبات بتضغط عليك كتير يا بتخليك
انك انت تقعد بالبيت وما تستمر بحياتك وما
تكمل لقدام او انه انت بدك تقيم العقبه
هذه وتقيم الصعوبه هذه من حياتك حتى لو
كانت شيء اساسي زي انك تلبس برجلك
انا حاليا
مره بحياتي ولكن اول مره بحياتي بطلع على
مسرح بدون ما البس برجلي ليش لانه بكل
بساطه اذا لبسته راح اتالم راح اعاني بطلت
اني انا الغي هالعقبه من حياتي كلياتها
على وجهك مثلا الناس قدامي
على مسرح من غير بوته عادي
[تصفيق]
مدام انا واقف على المسرح عم بوصل الرساله
عم بحكي للناس كيف تستعمل
الموبايلات بشكل احسن لتساعد غيرها من
الناس
والنقطه الثانيه هذه فتحت فتحت يا حديثه
اللي هي انا سعيد قفاص وانا اكثر من مجرد
مصمم
ايش يعني اكثر من مجرد مسمى
بحياتنا
كلياتنا عنا مسميات
هذا طويل هذا عصير هذا ناصح حدا يخيف انا
دكتور هذا مش دارس شهاده عن سؤال
هاي المسميات بتحثنا بصندوق
الصندوق هذا مليان صور نمطيه لما انا اجي
احكي انه انا اكثر من مجرد مسمعه هذه
الايام انه انا ما بحب المسمى تبعي بالعكس
انا شايفه شيء عادي نعم انا شخص من ذوي
الاعاقه ما بقدر انكر هذا الاشي ما بقدر
انا اظلني اقول لا انا مش ما عندي اعاقه
وخلاص يختفي الكرسي المتحرك تبعي
لا انا ذوي الاعاقه
فانت لما تتقبل هذا المسمى انت مشكلتك مو
مع المسمى انت مشكلتك مع الصوره النمطيه
الماخوذه عن هذا المسمى كثير شركات
لما تشوفي تاعتي اكون كاتب انه انا عندي
قصه
عن الخبره اللي عندي اياها بعدنا اشتغلت
خمس سنين بواحده من اكبر شركات الاتصالات
بالعالم واشتغلت عليه
بشركه امازون اللي هي
بالعالم بس لانه انا
عندي اعاقه
فلما انا اجي اقول انه انا سعيد قفاص وانا
اكثر مجرد مسمى يعني انا اكثر من ما انتم
شايفينه او ماخذينه عن هذا المسمى
انا سعيد قصاص وانا اكثر من مجرد مسمى